[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master danish
brush and this is how to prepare like a
pro
this time we are going to look at
carlson's secret preparation now this is
not the baby carlson
most people talk about
this is not the adult an ether
this is in between
so
this magnus carlsen actually worked with
a legend does anybody know who i'm
referring to when i say magnus and we're
talking about 2009 slash 2010
he actually hired
semi was invited to work together now
this
player slash legend who helped him
is also have known to have played him in
a rapid tournament in reykjavik
any guesses
for
this person
legend to this day and actually a
regular guest at the st chess club
mostly for ultimate moves
it is
not karpov
but gary kasparov yes so gary kasparov
famously
offered to help magnus carlsen
um in his growth as a player and this is
one of those first
efforts
that feels
that sort of came from this combo of
caspar kasparov and carlson working
together so e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6
and a lot of times you might be
wondering
especially if you're on the other side
or the other end of the pond and you're
pondering yourself okay
so
what is kasparov famous for playing
he played plenty of matches against
karpov
but
there's basically two big variations he
plays now even that doesn't always give
away enough information so i'm pretty
sure leko sort of predicted
some things that he's going to see in
this game but not everything
so you kind of expect
the direction of the surprise and the
preparation
but you might not know where it goes or
comes from so
famously in the karpov match
there was a
semi-sideline
that kasparov inflicted on karpov does
anybody know
which one that was
and we're of course not talking about
the rue lopez nero lopez obviously has
been a returning guest
um in that match in lyon and many other
ones later
it's of course
one of the big debate they had lots of
spanish games
but that wasn't really the surprise
weapon
that kasparov used against karpov
it was the scotch exactly
so
as time has passed by and that match was
around 1990s
um
carlson playing d4 isn't a surprise
because
you could predict kasparov is training
with him you may as well see the scotch
stick sticks and here layko played
bishop c5 not a bad choice by
a large
by lako because knight f6 was played in
that match
takes pawn takes e5
here queen e2 knight d5 c4
bishop a6 and this was well known even
back then but b3 was a novelty by
kasparov
which was kind of unpleasant
for karpov to face and even though this
game
which i'm gonna just show some snippets
he did survive
it wasn't without some blood sweat and
tears
so b3 this was the novelty by now this
is a well known system and an
established one
these days people play g6
but karpov played long castle
g3 rookie 8 bishop b2
f6 bishop g2 pawn takes
castles so this is actually a funny
position
in some respect because black is up a
single pawn however there is like a
downside for black's position
so
what do you think is the downside that
black is sort of facing here so if we
get into our scotch debate
and it's mostly about observing the
situation
trying to kind of guess what's misplaced
for black or what could be a potential
issue for a carpal
because this is from that kasparov
karpov
game
yes
the bishop like is kind of doing a job
right now but like
exactly so
the whole point
of uh
kasparov's system of going a to b three
c4 and just walling up that bishop is
that bishop will get mummified there
it'll never come back to life
um this is not an evanescence song
so
in this case the bishop is really bad
so
karpov decides to go for h5 and try to
attack
now
there is a fantastic documentary a
french documentary on this match
where you could see both sides you could
see kasparov and karpov just
rattled through the lines and tell their
mindset and what they were thinking
during the positions so
here
kasparov gave his explanation he played
queen d2
and wasn't such a great move that's what
he said in that documentary and he was
saying hey rookie one would have been
better you're going to win the e5 pawn
go for the ending and you should be
let's see a knight f6 takes
takes rook takes and because of black's
pieces being this harmonious white is
just better and you have
an extra pawn on the king side
but he played queen d2 and eventually
the game ended in a draw after plenty of
complications and
fascinating play from both sides
now
what's astounding though
is that when i looked at the engine was
checking what was going on the engine
did say queen d2
what a nice move and that was the move
that kasparov played and kasparov said
isn't the best now of course a lot of
time has passed since
but it's interesting that
in a bigger depth you may find rookie
one being stronger
but queen daytona lower depth is still
considered to be pretty good
maybe legends are still legends even
today
there weren't really that many strong
computers in the 90s so
the fact that kasparov sort of finds the
right move regardless of the fact that
ever any computers around that's still
very very commendable
but back to our game
let's come back to our game here laker
for that very reason he knows kasparov
is on team calls and he goes for bishop
c5
bishop e3 now there's two lines there's
one line of knight takes c6
this is the older line
queen f6
queen d2 is the old old old one takes
knight c3 bishop d4 etc etc this
actually featured in another world
championship match and that was between
xi jin
and susan polgar
and susan polgar had a second
helping her
who actually turned out to be pretty
good
her name is
judith bulgar
and
judith
kind of cooked up they kind of worked
together to play this scotch variation
against xi joon with an astounding
effect
because
xi jin didn't know how to respond
correctly
and susan
actually crushed that opposition and
zuzia became a world champion
so bishop e3 this is another line queen
f6 pawn to c3 knight e7 bishop
c4 classical way of playing g3 was
popular at some moment i had some fun
experience playing this line the point
being you're trying to put pressure on
the d5 square
but bishop c4 is a bit more direct
and it controls d5 immediately
knight e5 bishop e2
queen to g6
now this so far is nothing new this has
been seen before
but it's a double attack
the question is how should we respond
now
don't forget we are talking about
calls and preparation this has been seen
he knows what's happening
so
sometimes you can expect and you could
expect some very very brave play
by
the white player of course because he
has seen this position previously
at home
castles
the point is
you are going to have if you go queen e4
knight b5 ideas and you as your king is
still stuck in the middle
while my king is in safety means i have
a very very sound attack going
it's d6
now layko knew this um leko if you don't
know of course was a world championship
challenger played a match against
kramnik and wasn't far off from actually
becoming a world champion
so
if we're talking about someone who's
very theoretical it is peter lakoe he
knows the ins and outs of the e4e5
systems
and he actually used it with great
effect against vladimir kramnik in his
match
so
so far lakewood is in book
and even though castles is quite an
astonishing move by in itself
it's not really the bombshell that
magnus is trying to show
now
you want to
be
very very aggressive in this position if
black manages to castle consolidate
blaco is going to be more or less solid
and mean we see leko get a solid
position that means most of the time
that he is out of danger
so our job here
is to look for a play
where
white can go aggro
yeah
knight b5 so there's a little bit of a
difference if we go here if we go knight
b5
they capture here
and previously
this pawn wasn't really
defended but here i can go king d8
wait
i think i can do that as far as i can
see yes
takes your
knight is gonna get stuck
as far as i can tell
although it would be pretty logical
but event for this move f4
f4 and the idea is that up i'm not going
to give you time to consolidate so if
you just move back i am just going to
roll you down with f5 f4 f5 and you're
just gonna get squashed
well especially notice that this bishop
on c8 is completely passive and can't
move
so layko is taking up the gauntlet and
takes on e4
good move bishop f2
pin f4 and well queen f4 wasn't played
but the problem with queen f4 here now
knight b5 actually gains strength
because if you take here rook takes f2 i
hit the queen and i threaten this the
same time
so bishop f2 takes pawn takes knight g6
now so far laiko's been playing the best
way possible
but here comes
magnus's true novelty
and this move
is kind of cold-blooded
so
we found the aggressive one let's try to
find the cold-blooded move as well
it always boils down
to threats
one of those things i always talk about
when i teach
is threats always look out for what your
opponent is trying to accomplish
black is clearly trying to
pick carlson's king side into pieces
so it goes for this very cold-blooded
move of pawn to g3
and pawn to g3
is quite
something normally you don't want to
open up
your king side especially when there's
already a queen there
attacking the king
now
if d5 there's bishop d3 and strong play
against black's pieces
and uh here
actually laiko had to emphasize this and
go for bishop h3
bishop f3
queen f5
rookie 1 d5 and this turns out to be ok
for black
however
whenever you're preparing for an
opponent there is sort of a
psychological evaluation going on
you're always trying to figure out what
is the mindset they're having
or what type of players they are
i already alluded to the fact that peter
lake is a very solid player
he
likes to
get positions
where he has no real issues whatsoever
or no risk involved
now
if you go bishop h3 there is still a
chance you're gonna run into prep
by carlson so it's a bit more dangerous
to go bishop h3 here if you don't know
what are you expecting
so team magnus actually correctly
predicted
that peter laco isn't going to go for
something that's
a bit shaky he will go el cemento as he
would yes he would put it he'd just
castle and say hey my king is safe i've
got the extra pawn how bad could this
get
so
we get this situation
laco manages to castle and now it is for
us to sort of prove the fact that we
have compensation for the sacrifice
spawn
now i gotta give you a little bit of a
heads up
magnus does have the bishop there
at his disposal
and that's actually
super duper important
why
well
the bishop pair usually is enough
compensation for a single pawn
it's
enough but not quite more than that
so our goal here is try to find
magnus's
strategy
in fact it's very logical what he does
in this position
yes
exactly so that's exactly what the
magnus did
knight to c3
queen f5
pawn to d5
and what is the point
of going this way because i failed to
ask that but i'm gonna redirect that
question to you
yes
and apart from the fact we've got the
bishop there now we've got
that central pool so we pushed laco back
as magnus carlson there is one piece for
laco that is still terrible
which one is that one
eric well the a-rook is a problem child
but it's not the main issue
it's the ca bishop
now we won't don't really talk about
this and i guess
most grandmasters don't like to get into
the nitty-gritty
of chess theory but most of the problems
you ever get in a chess game comes from
the c8 bishop
either because you wasted too many times
activating it or you wasted no time
and you just decided to play the french
opening
in either case
that bishop is not good
now there is reasons why the karakan is
kind of gaining in popularity to the
french because you're sort of dealing
with the issue of the bishop and plenty
of openings a good openings and one of
the best ones uh sort of solve the
problem and that's why they're very
playable and good systems
but a lot of cases the positions you get
they're bad because of that bishop
so here
laiko's issue is again that bishop on c8
and there's a great point in chat saying
his queen is blocking the bishop so
blank's job really should be to somehow
untangle
because yes
blank is solid enough it's not like laco
is losing on the spot or anything
but has some
issues sort of
getting these pieces and just
coordinating them
you can't really go bishop d7
because you run into bishop d3 and the
queen is already kind of getting shaky
now if you have the extra material it
always sort of
is a way of trying to
release the tension or
try to trade more
how could black sort of aim for that
and then of course we're going to see
how carlson's masterpiece unravels
can you play c6
now not really because if you go c6
i take and the pawn is hanging right
but the idea is correct
you want to somehow get c6 to work
how
is the question
yeah rook d8
rook d8 or it could be also queen to d7
and pawn to c6
trying to under mine it now it's not
what laco played and um there is
something that i have to tell for anyone
watching and saying oh obvious computer
says rook d8 queen d7 or which have you
both of them i mean seems very
reasonable to me
whenever you're facing a novelty and
like big preps by these
top and super gms
it's very difficult to keep your cool
and just try to find a logical solution
27 c6 even though very logical i mean
it's difficult to just choose out of the
10 other moves you could play here
because why that why not something else
now the reason this would be kind of
decent
for laco because after trades
potentially the bishop could get to the
diagonal and once that bishop actually
at least gets developed
you should be more or less
in an okay position
in a position which you can play
now laiko plays a6 and again it shows
that lako is
playing it solid
rookie one bringing your rooks on the
open files
king h8 rook c1
and a lot of times people just focus on
the fact that oh we sacrificed the pawn
but notice that
magnus's play is very unhurried
is there any bad pieces left well my
rook on a1 and f1 wasn't really playing
well i'm just going to involve them in
the game
bishop d7 okay so we've improved on our
rooks is there anything else that we
could try to improve
or any other square that could be of
great use for white
e4
sort of but it's a good question what
are you going to do once you get this
square
and if your knight gets to g5
what's the goal afterwards
okay
so that's one way of thinking
but magnus is going for a bit more
strategic chess so it's not going to go
for a checkmate an attack
soon or not yet
but by the way you're correct like e4 is
usually one of the strong squares but
the other one is d4
now
you have to decide what you want to put
there do you want to put a bishop a
queen or a knight
now if you put the queen there that's
always double edged because yes your
queen is going to be very strong but
also the queen can be in the way and
easily attacked
if you go bishop to d4 does that
accomplish much
no it doesn't really do too much yes it
puts some pressure on g7 but it really
isn't what we're playing against
if you look at the moves we played
then there's something by the way you
should always do
what is the direction
white's pieces are aiming at and that is
a giveaway
what you should be aiming to do in the
position
so
many of our pieces
are facing the queen side here right
plenty of
pieces lurking there but as i said
earlier if you get your queen in the
center that's not going to help you you
don't really have a target on a7 i mean
laco is a class player he made sure you
never have a chance to actually win that
pawn
hello hello
so
backwards pawns
their primary targets in the position
it's rook c1 your target is the c7 pawn
if you go queen d4 bishop d4 that really
doesn't add anything
to your line of play
so anytime you make a move it should
have and serve a purpose
so
when i see chad saying play pawn to a4
that does not necessarily mean it's a
bad move but i just don't see the
concept behind it
now sometimes our concepts are flawed
even if it's
lego sometimes
but it's better to have a concept that
no concept at all
because at least you have some idea that
you follow
so
magnus's plan
is to go after this one
but you can't because your knight is in
the way
so
what magnus is going to do
is this maneuver of getting the knight
to d4
now
you may find this
slow and it is very slow of a plan
there's a reason you can do this
what's the reason we can do this
what is the sole purpose and reason
we can go for this short knight e2 94
maneuver
so we've got the extra space on d5 well
it is somewhat semi close that's correct
but also note
that this knight is going to just go up
and move to knight e2 and knight to d4
and
with the fact that black is so cramped
these pieces are so bad
that central control gives that
chance for magnus to coordinate his
pieces even better rook c8 queen b3
attacking the b-pawn
knight e2
and you got to give credit where credit
is due
magnus's play has been
very smooth
very very smooth
because all of his moves serve the
purpose you can't really say the same
thing
by peter lako's play his move of king h8
even though
semi useful
isn't like probably the best move in the
position
and the bishop isn't great spawn
isn't doing too much
so magnus is making some headway here b5
knight e2
queen h3 knight d4
bishop g4
so leko is trying to conjure up some
counter play in this position
as he should
but
maglis is going to find a way to sort of
shut him down
so let's try to figure out
how us playing the white side could shut
down
blaco's play
and by the way this is actually
connected to preparation
because it's not enough
to have sort of internalized some ideas
but you have to
understand the concepts like
you can't really play this pawn
sacrifice line without really
understanding where your pieces belong
and that's what magnus is doing so well
all of the pieces he has in this
position
are functioning high functioning
so
whenever you have the bishop bear
your first thought
shouldn't be ah i'm gonna give it up why
wouldn't i give it up
right
so
even though
chet is being very pessimistic that
they're gonna find the move i'm less
pessimistic about that
yeah bishop g2
it's not actually a hard move so there
is a level of mystifying um these
fantastic players but you know they also
have studied fishers games
and realized hey if i got the bishop
there i'm going to keep them so bishop
g2 and vo allah we found carlson's move
qh5 but you know as i said before
and this time i agree this next move is
super hard and i'm not even gonna
ask
to be find this but
here the move
pawn to h4 is fantastic so
yes
i actually think you can find bishop g2
h4 now that
so
i'll be super honest here i believe
any grandmaster
from
2500
to
however much they would find these moves
with bishop f3
probably knight t2 knight d4
that's like 2550 and upper
but
this next move
by carlson is a carlson move
because
it really just
makes sure no
counter play ever is going to be had by
lako lako might want to lurk about with
bishop h3
and then maybe even think about some
sacrifices at some moment or knight f5
i mean knight f5 isn't that scary but
mostly bishop h3 so magnus goes h4 and
while it makes h4 such a great move it
completely restricts black's play bishop
h3 obviously is not on the agenda
anymore because i'm just gonna capture
it
and also i put your queen and the bishop
on ice
none of them are really participating
anymore
and with
three pieces completely sidelined black
isn't really
of any hope
of
actually succeeding here
so knight g8
rook c6
so there is a time
to amp up the pressure and there's time
to gobble some pawns
so pac-man mode continues
ship d7
pac-man mode
and now this pac-man mode actually works
beautifully
um
and the reason
that this one is
working
and
it's good is because these pieces are
sort of
out of the way and really isn't doing
anything
so now it takes v5
rook b8 a4
and
this is the
checking out part
for carlsen you got the advantage it's
probably decisive
but you still have to be on your toes
what do we have to know and do
in positions where we have a huge
advantage
take away counter play i think carlson
already did a good job with that
now there is another step that's
very important to take
what's that
so you got the extra pawn
it's sort of like getting the loot
you got to defend the loot right
so now g4 and lako is trying to
play spoilers here
bishop f3 so
watch how magnus basically puts an end
to all these shenanigans
bishop f3
nope you aren't going to go for
sacrifices your pin you take here i take
your queen
i take your queen there queen h6
queen c4
so
now there are a couple of steps one step
you put the pressure second step you win
the material but then you always have to
be vigilant because your opponent
doesn't have to give up roll over and
just say hey you're the better player
they can always play an aim for trickery
this move by laiko is a tricky one he's
either setting up knight takes h4 and i
takes f4 in both cases
it's not a guarantee he's going to get
full compensation but he definitely is
going to
get some play and can muddy waters
so magnus's move not only sidesteps the
spin but stops any of these tricks
because if you take i just capture you
and i'm up an extra piece
so these are those little trickies
that makes this situation work
for magnus
sidestepping ideas look for your
opponent's threats
knight takes h4 now laiko and
credit for him is still trying to do
something bishop takes g4 and again note
even though he is close to winning that
is magnus he's trying to minimize the
risk
if you take here well i already take
here queen takes h4
and it's already murky you might be even
in trouble
but magnus is on his toes takes here
first
takes now this looks scary but magnus
obviously calculated this
bishop f3
f5
just
taking away all the entry squares
because if the queen and bishop would
work together it'd be game over
queen h5
queen f4
bishop takes d5 so
there's always like a give and take in
chess
when you get the extra material you get
the extra piece extra rook
it's sometimes more important to provide
safety to your king
than
to have that extra pawn you give up the
extra pawn but you stabilize so
carlson's move of queen f4 is
stabilizing six
knight takes
bishop b7 rook b6 again
could take the pawn
but that's not stable enough well b6
just making sure layko doesn't get an
open b file to work with
f6
bishop d4 and here was another thing
that was trying to allude to
in this case
white actually has every single of his
pieces over defended
the bishop is over defended by the queen
the rook you really can't get close to
this one's defended these guys like the
c7 e1 those are the ones um carson is
looking out after
but as you have no real ways of
attacking them black is in big trouble
pnf7 knight e6 so he's quick to actually
put it onto a safe spot
king f2 safe spot moving away from the
danger zone
c8 bishop c3 just cutting off the c file
bishop d5 a5
just starting to run the a pawn
everything's under control also queen a7
no longer really poses any threats
because the rook is defended
look c4
knight d4 again closing off another way
in
for laco bishop a8 queen d6 now taking
the pawn
stopping queen d5 qh5
queen f4
rook e6 and here laiko realizing there
is no way through he resigned
so one of the first prime examples as i
want to show another one
and that's going to be a game between
dominguez and carlson
is that it's not enough to have
a preparation like a pro preparation
that calls and has you still have to be
understanding or have an idea what this
position is all about
so let's take a look at this game
this game between dominguez and magnus
carlson
e4 c5 and carson has played
these sicilians before
but guess what even though this is
played much later
he goes for the dragon
now
if i can quiz you people and i will
who was the player
who uncorked the dragon
in a match in new york
yes
kasparov indeed who was he playing
a legend actually he has been showing
some spectacular results quite recently
at uh some top event
anand yes against vichy
the big vichy anand the tiger from
madras
fantastic player and
talking about psychology now magnus is
inflicting the same pain
that kasparov did dominez is a very well
prepared player
but probably got got caught unawares
and did not expect the dragon to
actually show up
but
magnus just like kasparov in his match
against anand sort of relied on the
surprise value and of course they did
their hard work
ship g7
bishop c4
bishop d7 rook b8 and that's kind of a
different twist
so even if dominguez kind of sensed that
something is about to go down and think
hey
carlson is working
with caspar kasparov well
how about i do a little bit of a twist
now in that game so we can talk about it
a little bit
rook c8 was played bishop b3 knight e5
h4
h5
bishop g5
and queen a5 and this was the game
between kasparov and i mean anand
kasparov as caspar was playing black
now
believe it or not
carlson also essayed this variation
against judith polgar
and judah played g4 however g4 is
somewhat unsound in this position
and i wonder if you guys
know a bit of dragon lore
there are some typical sacrifices in
this position it's not that it
necessarily works here
but it's sort of connected to what
magnus played in the position
and it really has to do of understanding
the ups and downs of single moves
judith's move of g4
has an upside of being aggressive and
attacking and trying to push
magnus away or this night away however
it has a drawback a physical drawback
that actually magnus pounces on
and that is the f-bomb
it's no longer val protected so magnus
finds this very strong move of b5 you
can't really take this because i go
knight f3 and this whole structure for
white collapses
and after g5 there is this typical
sicilian counter thrust
b4 and after this
actually black has a very very good
position
white's attack is sort of dying down
while magnus's attack with a5 a4 is
coming very quickly
so
even though in this game cause and
played rook b8 it's not like he didn't
escape the more classical one that
caspar kasparov played and that's the
rook c8 line which is of course the main
line
in this one rook b8 is played with the
idea of pressing and opening up with b5
bishop b3
knight a5
all right so
a one of the ways of sort of
getting into a preparation mode is to
trying to make sense
of the variation you are going to be
playing
so let's try to make sense of this move
of rook b8 and knight a5
why would black play this way compared
to that play of kasparov
what could be the difference
i mean it has to be a glaring difference
obviously
because
these two moves just have completely
different purposes
why did black go rook b8
well you want to go b5
and
of course it does not necessarily make
sense to have your rook there
if you're not going to open up the file
so bishop h6 takes takes b5
and the point is
for black like let's say white goes pawn
to h4
b5
h5 is to go knight c4
and just have your rook
get an open file to work with and even
go queen b6 at times let's say take
sticks
this is a typical move of going queen b6
and hitting the b2 pawn
so
anytime you see these top players
play their games there's like a deep
concept going on and here the deep
concept
is to sort of play on the b file instead
of the c one
so knight a5 trades b5
g4 take sticks b4
knight d5
take sticks and
we'll have to stop here for a moment
if you look at this position
what do you think white will do in the
upcoming two moves
and this is super important because
there's nothing
other than your opponent that you have
to worry about in chess game
and if they find the best
she might just destroy you
she may just destroy you
now the knight on f6 is a key piece
in the dragon if that's missing
your almost borderline check made it so
probably lenny was not that unhappy with
the situation
however
magnus finds a way to consolidate
yeah
yes
so
h5 is brutal
so if black is just ignoring this you're
just going to get mated you are just
going to be absolutely shattered on this
side of the board because even if you
take the piece doesn't matter i have
like five pieces attacking okay only
three
the h7 square and you have no ways of
stopping checkmate
and we don't have mate on the other side
so your magnus finds rugby six
1
probably giving up on this idea because
of e5
and e5 is played anyways so if black is
going to place h4
black can go queen e7 or maybe even pawn
to f6 don't know which one i prefer
but in both cases one of the ideas to
trap the queen that pawn to g5 the queen
really doesn't have a way to get in the
game there's no real way to undermine
the structure and if you don't get mated
in the dragon
usually
black is doing okay or even better
the other move here would be queen e7
and you can also go g5
there's no real way
for y to break through
black is solid knight f5 i just captured
so e5 millennia takes which seems like a
correct decision some pressure on those
pawns
rook e3 rook f7 over defending the
bishop and the pawn like one of the
critical points in the dragon is to know
if your h-pawn is defended or your king
is safe enough if you kind of get a feel
to it and make sure you consolidate your
king side is black
the dragon variation can be very
playable
id2 d5
all about restricting
not letting lenny a come closer
at b3
queen c7 just activating his pieces
king b1
rook b8 all right so let's try to figure
out this move rook b8 which looks very
peculiar it's actually a very nice
um
move with
multiple plans involved
what could be
the big
upside of rook b8
rook c8 android cafe but what makes this
move so good
there's not just these rook moves
that rook b8 is preparing but a third
option
and that is pawn to a5 and a4
so you're not only preparing to have
direct threats on c2 but they also have
to worry about a5 a4
so these multi-purpose moves are sort of
the make or break of this position
rookie one rook c8
queen b6
d4 and he's sort of switching it up he's
trying to play in the center as he's
noticing that this rook is sort of
overloaded has to defend the d3 square
and the f3 one
for key five if you go rook d3
there is bishop b5 and you're gonna lose
one of the exchanges
which is probably lost at this level
d5 d3
opening it up for the pieces
takes
rook f3 and with dominguez's attack
dying down
this king on b1 actually is the one
becoming a target
i mean of course this is a brutal threat
i mean not quite yet you have rookie one
but
so that he could avoid queen g1 plays d4
bishop b5
again
trying to
push that king away in a corner rookie
three check
queen takes d4
so
it's not enough to be well prepared in
chess
if you sort of never really practice
tactics
and magnus just showcases this perfectly
and brilliantly
that
hey
it's good if you could make good moves
but you also have to be on the ball
when
the
situation kind of demands it and when
you have a tactics you need to find it
especially in the dragon because it's
all about taking the opportunity and the
chance that you're given
of course capturing here is not advised
because rook c1 is checkmate
and taking here is also ill advised due
to rook g queen g1
and then knight c1 then rook c1
and of course following made on queen
takes c1
6 rookie 6 check
queen g4
again cold blooded
takes well it doesn't matter i'm going
to take here i could also take on f1
um and he takes on e6
and basically black is up a pawn however
this is the situation
where
technique is very much important
can you guys tell me why technique
is so important in this position for
the black side even though we are up the
extra pawn
yeah our king isn't particularly safe so
if we make a couple of mistakes it is
not at all
unprobable that we get made it by
accident
so you want to avoid that
queen ticks knight c5 c
like dominguez has his own little
trickies
you don't pay attention boom you get
made it
we need to
rook c1 bishop f5 and that's that's what
it shows
that magnus even though he has the
better of it he does what he did in the
previous game against laco consolidates
you got the extra pawn you over defend
your pieces
in f4 a5 again over defending everything
h5
queen e7 coming back home
having a defender and pressing trying to
trade off
a rook bear
queen c4 bishop e6 another astounding
defensive move of course it's taboo
can't take there because your rook is
hanging
queen g5 you still can't take this
because i take and i take over on c1 you
lose
h takes h takes and it's scary i'll be
honest it's very scary of a position but
probably magnus is sort of getting
comfortable with the idea of getting to
bishop f7
setting up this battery
along the g8
and a
to diagonal and then
dominguez is going to have his own
problems on king problems e3 and i don't
like a3 particularly because it's sort
of weakening that diag even more takes
take between c3
takes king takes and this is what i was
telling you people the queen is coming
in
rook c2
a4
notice magnus isn't any of rush of
trying to find a forced mate
king a1
a3
queen e3
bishop f7
queen c3
g5
being e3 so dominus is just waiting
around but
magnus is
very very consistent in making sure
everything's guarded rookie eighth again
the rook was fleeting in the air moves
it to a better square in c3
rook e2
quite a move you take
you got mated
knight b3
wait
wait
did dominguez just blunder a piece
did he just blunder
yeah
exactly
so
what makes these super gm so tough to
beat that it's so tricky even at this
last moment when you think that ah this
is just like a last moment just to
despair there's a trick
so this would have been a draw because
even though you're up a queen a bishop
and two pawns it's a stalemate
well even if you move king over i can't
check you and i keep checking you
i will not have to remove your queen
from this square
so i will just keep checking you till
the end of time
so of course carlson doesn't fall for
this
takes
and plays queen e5 check
king b1
king g7
and again patience
not rushing is just so important between
d2
bishop takes b3 no more trickies
and here dominguez resigned
so
i really hope all of you enjoyed
these games
that i brought this game between carlson
and laco and dominguez versus carlson
all of a
bit of a kasparo recipe
but with a calls and twist so thank you
so much for being here
and tuning in to this
lesson
goodbye
[Music]
you